quand on pr l'unité de la France on ne
peut pas dire qu'il y aurait deux
Frances qui s'opposeraient l'une à
[Applaudissements]
l'autre il y a madame la sénatrice une
France celle des villes celle des champs
celle des cités celle des cœurs de ville
une seule France unie et dans cette
France il y a des délinquants et les
délinquants il faut les traquer il faut
les sanctionner il faut les punir et il
faut prévenir la population des actes
délictueux qui peuvent être commis par
des délinquants à crépool où je me suis
rendu ce sont des délinquants qui ont
attaqué de manière grave et qui ont tué
le jeune Thomas et blessé des habitants
de cette commune de crépool et des
alentours qui étaient venus se
rassembler pour faire ce qu'on fait de
mieux en France s'unir dans la fête et
dans la joie j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire à crpul ce n'avait ce n'était pas
une Rix c'était une attaque et il y a eu
meurtre et le motif de bande organisée a
été retenu par le procureur de sorte que
le suspect présumé de l'assassinat du
jeune Thomas est possible de la prison à
perpétuité ce que je suis allé dire à
crpol c'est que l'État de droit il est
fort il est ferme et il est le même pour
tout le monde aucune aucun facteur
potentiellement aggravant ne sera éludé
rien ne sera caché je salue l'action
déterminée des forces de police et
notamment de la gendarmerie une
mobilisation de 150 hommes a permis ce
qui est rarissime en moins de 3 jours
d'interpeller neu des prévenus dont se
avaiit prévu de partir en Espagne pour
prendre la
fuite madame la sénatrice personne
nignore et personne ne niitune partie de
nos compatriotes une grande partie de
nos compatriotes qu'il soient dans les
villes qu'il soi aussi dans les dans les
champs ont peur face à la violence qui
peut déferler mais je voudrais dire
aussi madame la sénatrice que ceux qui
ont peur et ceux qui vivent cette
violence au quotidien sont les habitants
mêmes des quartiers dont sont souvent
issus les délinquants et c'est aussi
vers eux que nous devons avoir nos
pensées parce que c'est aussi pour eux
qu'il faut rétablir la paix républicaine
et la concorde ils font partie de cette
France unie indivisible à laquelle je
suis sûr vous tenez et que nous
protégeons et à laquelle nous
tenons